Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill still and it's time for the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
March six,
2017 what's going on everybody?
I am in Phoenix, Arizona.
Um, isn't that exciting? Phoenix, Arizona.
Um, but actually gives man, I'm psyched.
I'm working at standup live doing two
shows tonight, two shows, Tuesday,
two shows Wednesday. Um, um,
you know, putting together my new hour
and everything and I got a bunch of shit.
I've actually been listening
to my act. I always, you know,
when I'm putting together a
new hour, oh, I always record.
I just never fucking listen.
Well now I'm finally listening to my act.
I figured it out when I can do it cause I,
who the fuck wants to sit there and listen
to yourself, but I'm doing is I'm a,
I listened to it on the car ride home.
Yeah.
You know, if I had a decent set, if I had
a shitty set, what's the fucking point?
You know what I mean? It's Kinda like
if you're always taping you, your team,
right. But you only watch if they win.
You know? I know people who do that shit.
They'd like know what the fuck happens
before they watch and if they lose,
they just don't even fucking watch.
So I've actually been watching
and that type of shit. And uh,
speaking of which your team winning and
losing all freckles came in last night
and I went to the Phoenix Suns were
playing, my boss did sell decks.
So I decide, you know what, I'm
going to go to that game, right?
My hundred and 17th fucking
franchise professional home team.
I've spot ever professional sports team
that I've seen a home game of hundred
and fucking 17 of these mother fuckers.
I got 10 more to go.
I can't get out any 10 every time I get
to 10 and I'm like, go one more team.
I'll fucking,
then I'll have nine left and somebody
moves and how I got down to 10 I'm like,
all right, the next one's going to get me
down to nine and then the fucking ramp,
the rams move back up to 11 right?
So then I go see the thunder and I'm
thinking, all right, look man, I'm down.
I'm down to fucking,
I'm down to nine and I'm like,
wait a minute.
Okay,
Okay.
I saw the New Jersey Nets.
I never saw the Brooklyn Nets,
so it's still 10 so I'm
like, all right, next week,
next week when I go see the sun's,
I'll be down to 19th left. Right.
So I'm sitting there watching
the signs and I'm like, Z,
I'm down to single digits.
The Fan Slam is going down.
One of the loneliest accomplishments ever,
I guess if you went with
a bunch of other people,
I got to find the old pictures of me
at these stadiums. I swear to God,
they're all like disposable camera
pictures held by a stranger. Um,
you know,
when I was doing all these fucking gigs
in the middle of nowhere and shit. Yeah,
I pass through the major cities.
I would just go to a Goddamn game anyways.
So last night I'm thinking, all right,
I'm going to the sun's Celtics game.
I'll have nine teams left. And I'm like,
wait a minute, the fucking charger.
It's just moved to Los Angeles.
So
yeah.
And then a month I'm working in San
Antonio and I'm going to a spurs game,
go on to the fucking spurs and then
I think I'll finally be down to nine.
You know, God forbid if the
fucking Raiders don't move
to Vegas after that. Um,
but anyways, I uh, I went
to the suns game, right?
Okay.
So I show up immediately. Um, the
club hooked us up with tickets,
gave us great texts who was sitting two
rows, find the fucking, one of the, uh,
what do you call it in basketball?
One of the nets, one of the goals,
one of the back boards,
right? Two, two rows back.
So it's really three rows back cause I
got all the fucking camera man, you know,
but still it's a great seats.
And I looked down on the right and is
this guy just riding the reps in the,
in the first quarter and
he really gives a shit.
So I'm looking at version and I'm just
looking over going to look at this
fucking, this guy's out of his mind.
There's a guy who gives a shit.
This is a hardcore season ticket
holder, man. Would come at you.
I'm laughing like he's just like,
he knows the refs names.
He's calling them out and all that shit
and version. He starts going on. He goes,
I bet that's the owner. I'm like, Nah, I'm
on. The owner wouldn't be sitting down.
He wouldn't be yelling like that if
he was the owner. And he's like, well,
Mark Cuban brides, the refs
like, Dad, I gotta get the
fuck out of here. So finally,
you know, I go, I man, I'm going
to look this guy up, right? So we,
we look them up and it's the owner.
I got to tell you, Phoenix Suns, dude,
you guys got a great fucking owner.
Uh, Robert Sarver is his name meant we
ended up talking to them at the end of the
game because I tweeted a,
I was making fun of 'em.
What's his face? His shoes, his sneakers,
the fucking worst sneakers
I've ever fucking seen. Um,
Kelly Olynyk,
the big white goof,
the seven foot fucking pylon out there,
right?
I don't, I, you know, Celtics love that
guy. He got so many God, their meds.
Maybe it's a road trip or whatever, but
do this. He had these fucking sneakers on,
I think Garrow your premium warm in the,
that fucking Superbowl
against the Redskins when he
fucked up the field goal too.
They were like,
they looked like black football cleats
from the early seventies the ugliest
fucking things ever seen. So of course
I tweet about, that's why I get,
so I tweeted about the thing and I guess
the owner's son was watching. He goes,
oh, he's probably sitting right
next to you, blah blah blah.
That's how I didn't meet the guy.
But anyways, long story short,
so I tweet about this fucking thanks.
Making fun of the guy's sneakers thinking
obviously these has to be the worst
fucking sneakers.
Without a doubt.
Even with the Internet,
even with Twitter,
even with all of these fucking
concept or on social media,
nobody can argue with the thesis, the
ugliest fucking sneakers ever. Right?
They will low tops,
fucking steel goal kicker cleats from
the fucking early seventies right.
And all these sneaker heads.
So like you mean,
you mean the Colby 11
I guess just to Coby Brian Seek.
And what because it says Colby on it.
All of a sudden the Colbys do do you
mean the shack 14 I fucking hate sneaker
heads of fucking can't stay at home with
the 5,000 fucking pairs of sneakers,
taking them out of the box, showing them
off on MTV cribs and licking the soul.
So it's like, you see, I never, I
never even wore these joints before.
Yeah. I can tell from your fucking man
tick she never worn before this sneakers.
Why don't you go take a fucking walking
him Bruce? He's a big sneaker head.
I'll tell you, you know what?
It is fucking overrated.
It's so fucking overrated.
Jordans.
Okay.
You know what I mean? I'm not saying
they're not good looking. Some of them,
most of them are fucking
ugly as shit and dude,
the fucking mouth breathing dope.
Maybe that's what it is.
See of fuck. Oh Jeez,
I'm walking around now.
I'm walking through the amount of
fucking dope that we're Jordans.
You know what it is about Jordans? It's,
you don't even have to fucking think.
You know what I mean? Oh, you
gotta do is get a pair of Jordans.
You know everybody's gonna like,
oh, y'all are those. The six is,
are those the Jordan six
is to look at these six.
I've got him with the black, with
the gold outline. Yo Dee Dee Dee Dee.
These sneakers are crazy,
right? These things are crazy.
You know,
I don't know.
Fucking mouth breathing Morin's with the
Goddamn sweatpants and they're Jordans.
You know, first he's a big
Jordan Guy. He loves Jordans.
See what he's wearing a pair of this week.
They've fucking ugly as shit.
They're all black.
And then they got like this white wall
tire thing down it just because it says,
George, I'm going to go, oh, Paul was to
check out these new George. You're like,
am I go? No, I actually, I don't. And
he can't understand. He goes, we did,
but they did their Jordans through
these, these, these are Jordan ones.
It's like, dude, don't give
a fuck if the Jordan Knight,
I'm so sick of the numbers.
Yeah,
do what's your favorite Jordans? You like
to seven's really? You like to sevens,
but you got to make sure that that it,
it just says Nike on the back.
If it has him on the back,
then those aren't the real ones.
The Colby 11
like what do you guys think
that if you fucking put them on,
you somehow going to be able to dunk.
You're going to score close to 80 points
in a fucking NBA game cause you're
wearing Colbys
the Sundale three seven.
Okay.
I Dunno, I, I don't understand any,
if a fucking sneaker's ugly,
it's ugly. I don't give a shit.
I cannot fucking book.
If you guys,
you have to go on and you have to look
at a picture of those fucking sneakers.
They like referee sneakers from
the fucking early eighties.
It's just a black low top fucking
slipper with the Nike swoosh on it.
Yeah.
Do you mean the Kobe 11 dude,
the Colby of,
of fucking crazy. The crazy Tony.
You get yourself,
you get yourself a fucking tracksuit and
you put on a pair of those dude over.
Oh, you go out to the club people,
people that, oh, are those the sixes?
I, I don't, I just don't understand
fucking basketball sneakers. Okay.
Some of our good looking,
some of them aren't they?
They drive me up the fucking wall fall
versus the funniest fucking human being
I've ever met in my life. Like
he's, he sees one of these guys,
like I love him to death,
but the shit that he likes it,
he likes obvious shit.
Okay.
It'd be like, dude, you know what I like?
You know what I like? I like amenities.
It's like, really dude, you like getting
extra shit, extra comforting shit.
That's amazing. You know, I never
really thought about that. I don't know.
I have to think about this to do.
I like amenities.
You know what I liked Paul? I like a
lack thereof. I like less than like,
who ever say to do you know
what? You know, what do,
is there anything better than pizza?
Is there anything better
than a great slice of pizza?
Dude, you know what I like?
I like a Bologna Sandwich Dude.
A Bologna Sandwich with white American
cheese and mustard due to the mustard
puts it over the top. It's
crazy. It's a joke. I mean, hey,
it's literally a joke.
I Dunno.
So it's like, does it even need, we say,
of course it's a Bologna Sandwich. Yeah,
it's fucking hits the spot.
Yeah.
Full mainstream. Do, do you know
what I like? You know I like,
I like a golden retriever.
Okay.
Do you know what's crazy?
A white picket fence.
I'm sorry, I got to get him
back on this podcast cause I w
yeah,
partner calls him Mr Maxim. Cause
everything that he likes, it's like,
it's,
he likes what everybody likes,
but then she's got this simplistic fucking
great philosophy. We're who'd be like,
Bill a bill.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with sweat pants? You
know, you can't argue with them.
I actually had, there's, there's nothing
wrong with it. It's just, you know,
the conversation. It's just like,
it's just doesn't need to be,
most of the conversation just
doesn't even need to be had.
Was there anything better than
just walking around in sweatpants?
Dude,
you put on a pair of sweatpants with
some Jordan threes over over to what is
better than having on a hoodie and
a pair of Kobe 11. [inaudible].
You go to a massage parlor and
she's jerking your deck. I mean,
am am I crazy? It's so it, it's,
it's showing. It's a literally,
it's a joke.
All right.
I'm sorry.
Fuck all you sneaker heads out there.
God bless you with your
little fucking hobby. Uh,
keeping your sneakers clean and you know,
fucking walking on your heels anytime
there's any sort of rubbish on the ground.
Grown fucking man.
Just walking like a God duck on the heels.
Okay.
Hey Buddy, what the fuck are
you do? I got on the seven,
what is it?
The first day of school,
Dude, you know what I
love? You know what I love?
Is there anything better than
when it snows on Christmas?
That's the type of shit he says. It's
like, no. Yeah, that's great. Paul.
I think everybody's pretty much in
agreement. I even the Jewish people,
like if it snows on Christmas,
you know what I mean?
It probably adds to their Chinese
food. I don't, where could,
a fob doesn't like a fresh blanket of
snow as long as it isn't a goddamn store.
Do,
do you know what I like amenities.
Is there anything better than
taking a steam? Uh, no. I mean,
you know, that's also, that is a great
thing that everyone is in agreement with.
You know what I like,
dude, I like fresh air.
Is there anything better than like non
polluted air when you breathe in? I mean,
it's crazy. It's a g, it's
literally, it's a joke.
Um, Jesus, I went on a
fucking tangent there.
Oh my God. For half a second. I
thought the recorder wasn't recording.
I forgot my fucking microphone. So
this might sound a little bit, dude.
He say anything better than just laying
in your bed and just waking up and doing
your podcast. I mean it's,
it's literally, it's, it's,
it's a joke. You know, I have to
look up these fucking sneakers.
How the Fuck Colby Bryant, one of
the greatest fucking top of what two,
three players of all time,
individual players, teammate.
He was a fucking nightmare. Um, you wait
til that fucking confessional comes up.
Um,
okay.
When you sit there, put in my
password here. Stupid Laker fans.
So we chant MVP at the guy.
I hate that Celtic fans are chanting
MVP at Isaiah Thomas. By the way,
it reminds me of Laker
fans that were always,
every time fucking Coby stepped on the
court and did not pass the ball and
scored 40 fucking points
and they lose again
and they have the bay.
Um,
did you see him dunk on that guy
and then they lost? Oh my God,
he's unbelievable.
Maybe if we get 58 free agents
in here and fucking Phil Jackson,
they can win a title
and VP. All right. Um,
not what he's doing. He's wearing the
Colby. So he's wearing the Colby loved.
I have to look these fucking sneakers up.
How ugly these God damn things are.
And the fact that these pockets,
sneaker heads, you mean the Colbys?
I mean the rep sneakers,
those fucking cleats just wearing,
he looks like fucking Ken
Stabler out there. Kobe 11.
You cannot tell me that this fucking, the
computer doesn't listen to you. Oh my,
those are fucking dancing slippers.
Jesus. At least he got the best.
He got the best color.
They come and pink becoming red and white.
They got a Miami dolphin color.
Do those literally looked
like women's sneakers? Like
okay,
you should have like the low cut socks
with the little ball on the back if you
were those fucking things.
And I'm looking at, look,
look at the 100 and $1,230
I bet.
I bet if I went on youtube and this guy
and I looked up Colby 11 I bet there's
some fucking asshole sitting
there licking the fuck.
Who was a guy fat Joe did that
and his MTV cribs and he got,
he had like chick off.
He's like the fucking Jordans.
Six sixth and then he licked the
bottom of them. It's like, do,
do you realize the sweatshop? But
those things were fucking Baden. Okay,
okay.
And you think those things didn't hit
the ground in there and God knows they
probably don't.
They probably eat those people go to
the bathroom at the fucking station and
you're going to lick the
bottom of those damn sneakers.
They were in a hermetically
sealed sneaker box. Dude.
They were in a cardboard box and were
shipped over here from the other side of
the world.
I think I'll put my tongue on them.
All right. I'm going to look this up.
I'm going to see if I can find that.
I'm going to find a fucking video here.
Coby 11th all right. I don't know why,
but of the first video that came up said
exploding poo and a guy had shit on his
face. No, I didn't think they
did that type of stuff on fucking
okay.
Coby 11 shoes.
All right,
and some asshole's going
to do a fucking review.
Yeah.
Nike Colby 11 Performance Review through.
These are the ugliest fucking
sneakers I've ever seen in my life.
These ones are actually worse.
Coby Brian gives the Bron James
his autograph shoes. Yeah.
God. What the fuck did they talk about
other than winning championships?
Okay.
That'd be like listening to the fucking
superman and like fucking Batman talking.
All right. Colby gives away shoes to
a fan. He was a shit all over the guy.
He's like the nicest guy ever.
Colby helps a bus load of sick children
get to the staples center by towing it
with his own body and his Colby
11th. All right, maybe I was wrong.
Um, Nike, Kobe, I gotta get
off this fucking subject.
What am I listen to some guy do
a fucking review of the sneakers.
Nike Colby 11 performance overview.
My initial thoughts.
I fucking love Youtube. Well, it gives us,
I guess you guys are
listening to my thoughts,
but I'm just being a fucking
moron. Anyway, let's get
back to the Goddamn game.
All right,
so Kelly,
a Lennox out there and is Colby
11 do they will fucking crazy,
dude.
You get a seven foot white
guy and Kobe 11 [inaudible].
It's all, it's all, I mean,
the black guys is still going to go right
around them and have their nuts in his
face when they dunk on it, but I mean
his, his feet from the ankles down, it's,
it's, it's all, it's going to be a
stitch of Joe. It's literally a joke. Um,
all right. Anyways, so we
got, we watched this game.
The owner of the sons is a fucking riot.
Um,
totally just watching him ride in
the referees, like old school guy,
you know, right down there on the court
watching the game and uh, you know,
he's not about some luxury box or
anything like that. Right. So anyway,
so we're watching the game
and the Celtics come out flat,
which you knew they were Gunna,
you knew they were Gunna,
cause they just beat the Lakers anytime.
I'm telling you this right now, gamblers,
gamblers,
anytime the any Boston
team, right? The why,
well I'd say the Bruins are the fucking
uh, Celtics going that west coast trip.
Okay. If you want to make some money,
bet against them the day after they play,
either the clippers,
the kings of the Lakers,
cause they fucking go to la.
And after the game they all go out.
They Bang a bunch of fucking broads,
a bunch of fucking actresses or
whatever the fuck it is they do.
And then the next game when they go to
San Jose, down to Anaheim, out to Phoenix,
up to Portland, whatever the fuck they
go next, there's always a let down.
So the Celtics come out flat, the
fucking son's are all over him. Um,
love of the guard was on the sons
was just as fast it seems as Isaiah.
So he was right up on them. Um,
frustrating the hell out of them.
And Isaiah had to think for
files in the first half. And um,
so we're watching the game and I'm
just going like, I fucking knew it.
I'm so excited to finally see this team.
I've been watching,
seen almost every game of this year and
they'd come out flat. I'm like, Oh man,
am I really going to the fucking
hangover game? Ah, what do I give a shit?
I got three fucking tickets would still,
you know,
it's a bunch of Celtics fans there.
They're all going fucking
nuts and everything.
We had like nothing to cheer about.
I think we were down by like
10 after the first half. Um,
and we just start chipping away, chipping
away, chipping away. First half was ugly.
I mean it was like a,
it was like a first quarter score
with like four minutes to go.
It was like 32 27 it seemed, maybe it was
like six minutes ago. So what the half,
I think they were both didn't the
forties. I don't even remember. And uh,
and I said Paul Jokingly, I go, you watch
the boats going to score over a hundred,
they're going to eat up or whatever.
So of course they come out and
everybody starts hitting their shots.
It turns into this great game.
Um,
yeah.
And then the fourth quarter comes and
we start chipping away, chipping away,
chipping away with down by like 10
or 11 and then went down by eight,
then went down by five and then
without my, for next thing you know,
we're up by like two. So you guys all
know how the fucking game ends, right?
Okay.
We fucking missed what's
his face? Uh, Brown ms,
that foul shot and Isaiah,
Mr. Foul shot that would
have fucking ice tea and a,
we let them hang around, hang around
and fucking hang around. In the end.
I came up with was tired and we were up
by one. It all happened. So you know what?
It happened so fucking fast.
When you're at the game and you don't
have an announcer holding your hand and
you don't have something that
you can actually look at,
there's too much shit to look at. So
we go to inbound. The fucking ball.
Yeah,
right. This guy goes around Jae
Crowder, I think tied it up.
We'll like SLAAC right.
That's right.
We were up by two instead of being up by
three and force him to take a three and
they probably would have missed
a fucking thing. That's right.
And the guy goes right around, Crowder
lays it in, crowd's going nuts.
There's like four seconds left to go high
and they can try to get into I Isaiah
Thomas. Let's see what happens. We
fucking inbound the ball. Isaiah,
one of the only times I've seen a
mess up this year messed up the past.
Who's kind of looking up court,
you know,
cause there's only four seconds
left before he caught the ball.
They kick it out to this fucking dude.
What the hell was his name?
I actually wrote it down so I would
give him the respect he deserves.
Tyler ulous,
they kick it out to him and he hits a
fucking three point or at the buzzer to
beat the Celtics. And here's the
thing, I had second row fucking seats.
And guess what? I didn't even see
the play. It happened on my end.
You know why? Because the
fucking assholes who are in the,
they're in the front fucking row.
They inbound the ball and
they could see that, you know?
Okay.
Um, Thomas was, was fucking
it up. They stand up.
You read the Front fucking rob,
what are you standing up for?
There's nothing in front of you.
You fucking cons.
And all of a sudden I just saw the
ball go to the net and everybody goes,
and where the horn goes off, everybody
goes nuts. I go, what the fuck
does that count? Did that just go
with what the fuck just happened?
I had to go home to watch the replay
to see what the fuck happened.
I was sitting in the second row.
I couldn't see it because he's fucking
assholes stood up in front of me. Um,
I don't, I don't understand standing
up when nothing's in your weight.
They haven't,
you ever heard that expression?
Okay.
Why Stan? When you could sit
by, sit, when you can lay down.
Why stand up when you were in the front
fucking row and what is block and your
God damned here anyways.
All right, I'm done.
Fucking bitch in here.
I had a,
I had a great time and evidently
Kobe are fucking crazy man.
You know
dude, Chris Everett should wear that
fucking sneaker. That's what it looks at.
It looks like the one that different
colored ones. I'd like, you know,
do you know something that is a
testament to how great Colby Bryant was.
You know,
it's almost like he's so fucking good.
Nike was at the factory going like,
how fucking ugly do you think we could
make a sneaker if we put your name on it?
These people that lick the
bottom of the fucking sneaker,
will they still buy these God damn things?
You know what?
Now that I'm looking at
him cause I'm an old man.
They don't look like you
played basketball. Great.
They look comfortable as hell as far
as when they're in a different color,
I guess.
Okay.
They look like slippers.
They is,
the thing I want is, I want to fucking
ask you. Colby had that horrific, uh,
Achilles, um, injury. I
swear to God, which is like,
that was the end of anybody's career.
That is like the classic
old man basketball injury.
As you go to take a step in your fucking
Achilles goes right up the back of your
leg. Um, I mean,
I don't even think I obviously,
I don't fucking play hoops at all,
but I still fucking,
I'm always stretching my fucking Achilles.
I swear to God before I get out of bed.
That's,
I don't know what it is about that injury.
I just know like five or six people that
have had it and I want no part of it.
Okay.
I want no fucking, you never walk right
again. I mean, if he got Colbys money,
you know,
you can go to Germany and meet the
grandsons of the Nazi fucking doctors and
they'll spend your fucking blood in a
centrifuge, whatever the fuck they do.
And then you come back and you can
still dunk or whatever, you know.
But most people don't have Coby money.
So what's going to happen is as you're
going to go down to the veterinarian down
the street and he's going to show that
thing back and you're never going to,
you're never going to be,
you know,
that's it.
God help you.
If you're ever in a situation where
there's panic and the crowd starts running
and it's a stampede and you've blown
out your Achilles at some point in your
life that you're going to get trampled,
you know,
you're going to be that zebra on the
Serengeti that gets eaten by the fucking
alligators. Basically what's going
to happen. Um, but he, you know,
he has the low tops. I wonder if that
probably had nothing to do with it.
I'm just surprised guys are wearing low
top fucking sneakers again. Like, it's a
okay
cause it, you know, I don't
pay attention to shit.
I usually watch hockey right at
first he's going like, no, no, no.
Colby kind of brought the low tops back.
Everybody's wearing.
So I looked out on the court and I saw
a number of people with low tops are
people still had like
these high top sneakers on,
but the amount of ones like that,
that they were like velcro.
You don't like a little kid,
he can't tie you sneakers. See,
have they had like velcro high tops with
like a fucking belt around your ankle?
And I,
I dunno,
I don't know about those either.
You know what's hilarious?
How arrogant I am that I actually think
that the world cares what a 48 year old
white guy thinks about fucking sneakers.
Well,
why don't you just get a pair
of shell toes. Um, so anyways,
we went to the Goddamn game and uh,
we a great fucking time.
Uh, Robert Sovereign, his family are
great. We met, we met him briefly.
Just talk to them. Just great
people like that guy. Dude,
if I was afraid expense, I would be
very happy with that guy. As an owner,
even though I know you guys are rebuilding
that guy, fucking gloves, his team,
there's a lot of owners, they
don't give a shit. You know,
they own a team so they can have hookers
and blow up in a fucking sweet dude.
That guy, he was, it looked
like he, I was going to say,
it's like he had money on the game and
he does. He's paying the fucking players.
MMM.
Anyways. Um, all right, so
let's plow ahead here. Um,
I should probably read some
goddamn advertising right
here. All right, Luke Craig.
Oh, give me the loop. Uh,
be the NBA. Your friends,
be the envy of your friends. Why would
you want your friends to be envious? Gee,
I wish they had what you had and
get a hundred percent exclusive.
Craig's at Luke craig.com/burr and enter
my code burr to save $3 off any new
subscription.
Wait until I tell you about March's crate.
It's wild.
All capital letters.
Why it's wild on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fen
fanatical fashion needs stuff.
Yeah,
I hate that. Fucking fanatical
Fashionista. Then try loop where?
Monthly wearables and accessories and
coke classics and your favorite franchise.
Okay.
Oh with you have coke classics
and your favorite franchises.
MMM.
What? Fanatical fashion. He said,
what the fuck does that mean?
Offer expires March 19th at 9:00 PM
that roar and the distance is a call.
Will you answer it?
This month we're going primal
and unleashing the beast
of some of pop culture's
most ferocious franchises.
They love alliteration with the efs.
Fucking fantastic.
This march experience,
iconic items from Overwatch,
Wolverine,
Jurassic World and Predator, including
as always our monthly tee shirt and pin.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr
and enter my code burr to save $3 off on
any new subscription today. Hey
nerds, I don't know what the fuck.
I don't even know what that is.
Did you guys have a dental?
He love it and you're buying the shit
cause they keep advertising on my podcast.
I know what a Predator is.
I know Wolverine is,
that's when that Australian guy has to
eat a whole fucking chicken to get jacked.
And I was reading the other day,
that guy,
he's played wolverine eight times and
he has to pack on like 25 pounds of
fucking muscle.
He goes,
I eat a whole chicken every day because
my jaw is literally sore from eating.
It's like,
why don't you just do Roy?
Okay.
You know, it's not like they
test you as an actor. Uh,
did you hear about the fucking wolverine?
Gay can't make any more movies.
He got suspended for three
movies. He did steroids, um,
me undies. Oh boop, boop,
boop me undies be undies watching the
Phoenix Suns. But Dude, dude, dude, me,
undies me undies Olympic
is a fucking bomb.
He's fucking seven feet.
I don't give a fuck.
He's got the lateral movement of a fucking
dump truck. I don't know what to say.
Anyway,
you balls will feel nice and fucking soft
when you're wearing the Colby eleven's.
They're fucking Oakley. Um, me undies,
the lateral movement of a dump truck. I
know it does. Whatever. It fucking rhymed.
You can at least give me that Mandy,
she was one of the following
openers in your read. Okay.
Elevate your underwear game to
the next level with me undies.
MMM,
you've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if
you've been settled. Dude.
Is there anything better
than a new pair of underwear?
Okay.
I mean, it's crazy. Your balls
are alive. You know dude,
you have on a new pair of underwear and,
and you have the old Linux sevens on.
I'm telling you, dude, and you go to,
is there anything better than a bowl of
fucking great nuts? Um, great nuts, right?
You fucking, you. You're nuts. So
fucking comfortable. Your grape nuts.
A cause or a soft you.
It's going to be a great day.
You put on your sweat pants, you
get a slice of pizza. You know,
somebody says something, you go, Oh,
if you've been settling for store
bought underwear, five packs,
I have something that will change
your life for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put on
in the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me undies.
What is me undies?
Oh,
just seriously soft and feel good
undies delivered right to your door.
Biondi you've be phonies of Kelly.
Olynyk actually hears this and kicks me
in my red nuts with this fucking Kobe 11
[inaudible] that would really be justice.
There's your lateral movement.
You're wanting, your balls is going this
way. The other's going the other way.
You know something. That's why I think
you have a ball bag. You know what I mean?
Cause it hurts so much to
get kicked in the balls.
God had to give you balls the
opportunity to try to get out of the way.
You know what I mean? It's like a running
back that knows how to take a hit.
You know you can't have like,
like Earl Campbell,
just one in straight up and down. You're
going to end up in a fucking wheelchair.
You know what I mean?
I know Jim Brown doesn't like it,
but these running backs that step out
of bounds, they prolong your career.
That's what your balls are doing. And your
ball beck. All right, back to the book.
Copy here, me undies are
designed in La. Oh Jesus.
And made from sustainably
sourced micro modal. Modal are,
it's a fabric three
times softer than cotton.
Evidentaly me undies softer
than socks. Lugs, undies.
Isn't that supposed to be luxury?
Lux Z Luke?
Say undies come in and ever changing
selection of classic colors.
Maybe you can find some to match your
Jordan's sixes through to say anything
better than walking around in your
underwear and you find some Jordans.
Sevenths that match. I
mean, it's fucking crazy.
If you're wearing a bathrobe
and you smoking a cigar, I
mean it, dude, it's over.
It's literally a joke.
Um,
Biondi softer than soft, isn't it too?
Does anything better than free porn? Um,
bold shades and advertise it.
Adventurous patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your
own personal style. And guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready
for a subscription, that's
okay. You can still say,
that's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr
and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear
drawer. You deserve it. Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr me,
undies.com/berm ah, Jesus. Here we go.
Oh my God. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody. You know what?
I'm going to read one more of
these cause I got three left.
I want to take a break.
You know what I mean?
I can't be fucking reading
all these Goddamn ads.
Dollar Shape Club don't.
There's no reason to use it.
Cheap disposable fucking razor.
Oh pay ridiculously high prices kid for
some gimmicky fucking thing that's got a
laser point. It was 17 blades.
Make the Smad at choice.
Make the Marcus choice.
Make the smarter choice and Join Dollar
Shave Club before dollar shave club.
It was either saved money and get a
painful shape from a disposal disposables
like the one that give
away for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving with the piece
of glass or you pay a fortune for the
latest gimmick.
He shaved breakthrough.
You don't need like a laser
chin detector or 17 more blades.
Yeah, do the only thing you need
two blades. One blade sucked, right?
It's one of my lady shaving my legs over
here. Two blades was the shit. Three,
three blades and on fucking horrific.
It just got too big.
He couldn't get underneath the nose and
I got a cute little button nose and even
I had a problem, you know, can't
imagine if somebody was one of them,
them were Roman noses. You know when
those gladiator noses, Mediterranean.
I can't say the obvious choice here
because everybody would get offended,
but you know what I mean? I those poor
people, what they've been through.
Can you imagine? Then all of a sudden
there's this fucking three blades. I mean,
does the suffering Everett?
Okay,
get it.
Get a close,
smooth shave every time and you can't
beat the convenience or the price of the
club if you haven't tried dollar
shave club yet, you're missing out.
Fuck is this,
I set my alarm for 8:00 AM.
Why would I do that?
Oh,
I know why I got to pick up the rental
car and I forgot I had to do my podcast,
but I just woke up like a goddamn
machine knowing wait a minute,
I got to do my podcast. Um,
get a close shave, close,
smooth shave every time and you can't
beat the convenience of the price if you
haven't tried dollar shave club yet,
you're missing out.
It's an amazing shave
at an affordable price.
There's no smarter choice in the market
and right now that giving away what one
month trial for any of their razors for
a dollar with free shipping. After that,
it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no longterm commitments,
no hidden fees.
And you can cancel whenever you want.
A get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar shave
club.com/birth all
right. Okay, here we go.
Here we go. Here we go. Let's
get back to the fucking podcast.
So I've been listening to a bunch
of fucking old school country,
not all the way back to Hank Williams,
but like that outlaw shit, you know,
right before the outlaw shit is
George Jones considered outlaw,
I dunno.
But listening to him obviously,
um, to all of these other
fucking guys, right.
And uh, I ended up list,
I remember that this song,
do you guys remember Johnny paycheck?
Johnny paycheck was this country
singer and he, I swear to God,
he had a hit song called
take this job and shove it.
Okay.
And it was such a fucking hit.
It's so struck a chord with people that
they actually turned it into a movie.
There was actually a movie called take
this job and shove it. It was just,
it was about a fucking guy who was working
in a job that he hated and he wanted
to tell them, you know, basically
tell him to go fuck themselves.
But he didn't have the nerves.
And I think it was because the lyric was,
someday I'm going to
get the nerve to say it.
And everybody could relate
to it being like, Hey,
I also hate my fucking life
and I want to make a change,
but I don't know how to do it.
You know what I mean?
It's like the whole Donald Trump fucking
phenomenon, not the informed people.
You know what I mean? I'm talking
about the, the, the mouth breather.
You know what I mean?
Like put the Hillary Clinton,
you had the informed person that wanted
to vote for her and then you had the
hissy fit. Fucking dope.
This'll be great for women.
Like your life was really going to
fucking change. Um, I swear to God,
I just don't,
I don't,
I don't understand adults who haven't
fucking figured it out yet. That you're,
you're on your own. Okay. Playtime is
over. Nobody cares about you. Okay.
I don't care what color their
fucking tire they put their bra is.
They don't the level of money that you
have to have and then you have to give it
to these people for you
to even be on their radar.
You have to be going to these 10,000
hundred thousand $50,000 fucking plate
dinners with them,
and then you'd have to stand in a line
of people that all paid that money.
Okay? And you got to get up there
with your fucking shape shifter,
fucking lizard eyeballs, and you
got to try to peer into their soul.
I didn't think it talked to him.
You just walk up with a Napkin that says
how much money you're going to give to
them and then you're on the fucking radar.
Has nothing to do with your
genitalia anyways, so all the, okay,
so I'm getting off the rails here.
So this fucking guy, Johnny paycheck,
he's got this fucking Sean Song
called take this job and shove it.
It's the funniest fucking just,
there's no way to listen to this
song and not fuck it. Just be,
I played it for Paul Versey. He
was crying and laughing. He goes,
this can't be a real song. I go,
dude, not only is a real song,
it was turned into a movie.
Just the way he says shove it is
voice drops way down. He goes,
take this job and shove it.
I work in here no more.
My warm and dawn left.
Took all the reasons why I was working
for these are the actual lyrics you it or
not tried to stand in my way
because I'm walking out the door.
You could take this job and shove it.
I work in here no more than this
stupid baseline comes on boob but do,
do, do, do, do and it gets
all like kind of trying to
quiet. You don't want to, red neck gets
quiet, you know and starts talking,
leans in. It's fucking scary. You know,
nine whites even for white people.
That's fucking scary.
There is nothing scarier than a redneck
lean and in at a bar thinking that you
were, we're all on the same team.
That's some fucked up shit cause you,
you're immediately like, I
don't want to do, I don't,
I don't want any part of what
you're about ready to tell me sir.
And I want to try to get out of
this conversation gracefully.
How do I dismount out of this fucking
conversation that the second they went on,
a fucking redneck looks the opposite way
of the conversation and then leans in.
I'm telling you,
they should be like a fucking,
I'd inject her seat on your bar
stool to get you the fuck out of.
Where did it go?
Did I get left behind?
So I swear to God, somebody gets into the
verse, right? It's like he's leaning in,
have been working in this factory for now,
15 years all his time.
A watch my woman drowning in
a pool of tears. You know,
and I, when I love about all
those old school country songs,
is there a fucking women always leave?
They're always crying or whatever,
but these fucking assholes.
They never say why.
And whenever I listen to these
songs, it's just like, dude,
what the fuck were you doing? I get
it. You're working at this factory.
You don't like the job. Why is your
woman drowning in a pool of tears? What?
I mean, are you taking this
fucking so you don't have the balls
to try to get a better job? Tell your
boss to fuck off. So what happens?
You come home, you take it out on
your wife. Is that what you're doing?
I bet. Shit jobs. I've had
law for the first fucking,
I don't know how many
years of being a comedian.
Okay.
Was it a low paying job? I never had a
girlfriend drowning in a pool of tears.
I mean, I definitely made him cry,
but that's cause I was an asshole.
Had nothing to do with my fuck.
I wouldn't blame my job.
I've been featuring on the
road for now on 16 years.
One of these days. Anyways, he got,
he just listen to the fucking song.
You got to hear this song.
You got Johnny paycheck.
Um,
I know I'm making fun of him,
but I actually,
okay.
I don't know.
There's something about this.
I listened to this fucking song and it
just gives me all kinds of ideas for
characters and shit like that
and movies and whatever. Um,
but I'm in download, George Jones,
George Jones, Tammy, why net?
All of these fucking
people and I swear to God,
okay,
you gotta, you gotta listen
to George Jones these days.
These days I barely get by
is inadvertently one of the funniest
fucking songs you ever going to listen to
your life.
Do you have one of those friends that
just calls up and complains all the time?
Okay.
And did you try to help them out and
go, hey, well what if you do? No,
I can't do that and we'll blow the
fucking guy who was just resigned himself.
Yeah. Hey, it wasn't my walk this way, x,
Y, and z. What happened? That's why can't,
what's that fucking attitude?
That's exactly what's going to happen.
You know what I mean? I got a couple
of friends like that after awhile.
You just like to, you're a white guy
and the United States of America.
How far down the fucking track before
the race starts? Do you have to be
Jesus fucking Christ? How the
fuck are you complaining? I'm
complaining. I'm not saying that white
people should not complain. I, okay.
I know there's a lot of people drowning
in a pool of tears harder these days.
I'm going to get the, I'm going
to blow my top. It's like, dude,
why don't you just address the
fact that you don't like your job?
Apply from some other jobs.
If you don't have the training,
take some night courses.
You know,
get the training you need instead of
sitting there seething coming home,
taking it out on your fucking well,
George Jones has another fucking song.
Okay.
Called the grand tour.
I listened to them. I'm telling you, you
got to listen to these fucking songs,
right? I listened to that
song. It's like, George,
what in the fuck did you do to your woman?
Yeah.
It's like step right up.
Come on in.
If you had wall to tag the Grand Tor,
oh,
below we house. The awards
was home. Sweet home.
You're like, Jesus Christ and this mother
Fucker, he goes through his whole house
over there.
Okay.
Is the chair where it should bring the
pipe or to me and sit down on my knee and
whisper, oh, I love you. Hey,
you're like Jesus Christ right there.
You want to get out of the house?
This mother fucker won't stop straight
ahead is the bed where we lay in the low
boom.
When he gets all the way to the nursery,
you're like,
oh Jesus Christ.
Here he goes.
She took the fucking baby and the key
thing in all of this is he says there's a
rings and other things and
it's like this fucking woman
left all of her stuff and took the baby.
George, what the fuck did you do to her?
Okay,
this woman didn't leave you.
She fled the fucking scene.
There's some sort of detail.
You're not fucking given me here.
Where are the empty booze bottles?
I mean, what do you, what do you,
what did I actually listened to that song?
I feel bad for the woman in his
life until I found out she left.
Then I actually feel good.
Yeah, get the fuck out.
I didn't get that kid out of there. Tell
me if I'm supposed to feel bad for you.
Sounds like you went out back to
chop some wood and she just grabbed,
she saw some daylight, somehow got the
chains off around her fucking ankles,
grabbed the kid and get the fuck out
of there. Um, anyway, so it's recently.
Oh, there's gonna be some pure
country fancy and be like,
you're missing the point,
man. Take this job, man.
Show that night working
here. The more. All right.
Pro Flowers. Everybody
warm and burn. Blab, me,
my woman, Doug left me. Hey
Johnny. Paycheck. Come on.
It's just, you would make, Whoa, what did
she, what, what, what'd you do? You know,
I imagine if she fucked around on you,
you would have mentioned it. All right.
Maybe I'm taking these fucking
songs a little too seriously. Um, I,
I have a problem with that. Like when
I listened to rap music, you know?
Okay.
Like who sues that new group
that everybody's Migos. When I,
when I watched the videos,
shit,
and they're coming up in those supercars
and they're holding the fucking money
out. It just, it literally, I have
to look in the other direction. Okay.
Okay.
It just drives me nuts. Seen artists doing
that? I just, I'm always thinking ahead.
Please,
please buy some real estate.
Okay.
Please don't blow it all
on fucking Coby eleven's.
Oh my God, Dude. Watch an
artist's watching people
who don't understand money,
I guess. But I would say artists,
you know the shit that we fucking do.
It's just the dumbest.
Okay.
You know what's another
stupid fucking thing?
I love these people that buy watches
that are like you can, it's like, dude,
that thing you can hang
that on the fucking wall.
I'd know what time it was from across
the room. Why do you have that on that?
On your wrist?
The amount of guys that are
like my height and my size.
Okay.
Walking around with a watch that only
would look right on like a fucking
offensive lineman is, it's, it's like,
did you take that out of a submarine?
Is,
is that like deep sea scuba dive
and shit? So you can have, you get,
you can go fucking go down to like what?
9,000 feet and up with the,
the Goddamn dial won't bust on it.
I got my a big Oh watch.
Okay.
Paypal in a different time
zone can tell what time it is.
Take this watch and shove it. All
right. Pro Flowers. Everybody.
Have you ever forgotten your anniversary?
If you're not nodding yes, you're lying.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck it says to this?
I don't forget my anniversary.
Okay.
Again,
I'm not going to lie to you.
It definitely sneaks up on me when
I'll be off pockets in two days.
What can I get her? What can
I get her? I don't have time.
Maybe I'll get her some fucking flowers.
Um,
you know those people that
are just hard to shop for?
Like your wife for your anniversary
or your sister for a birthday.
It's just the worst. Trying to find that
gift. A you don't know. You don't know.
Yeah,
I think they're supposed to say what
you don't know what the like and be.
It's just the worst. Trying
to, okay. It's just the worst.
Trying to find a gift that a,
you know, they'll like and B,
won't cost an arm and a leg. Well,
I'm going to make it easy for you.
Pro Flowers is my goto for flowers is
actually a flower store down the street.
That's my fucking go to. I
hate the Internet. You know,
I'll go on there and I'll try to click
on something and next thing you know,
I'll eat.
They eat the order.
Either won't go through all our have
enough fucking funeral to re no funeral.
I'll have enough fucking
flowers to rebury Elvis.
That's what I was trying to say.
Then I just started picturing his funeral.
Anyways.
Pro Flowers is my go to for flowers.
Yeah,
they're fresh price. Right. And a
perfect gift for literally anyone.
Oh yeah. Get one for your guy
friends. That's a fucking gift.
Do you just want to freak out?
When are you fucking friends?
Just getting some
flowers and have the car.
Just say thinking of you and then
you write in parentheses smile
and they get delivered straight
to your recipient store.
How easy is that a right now?
Go to pro flowers. Right now.
Pro Flowers has a special gift
offer. Uh, just for our listeners,
get $10 off your
purchases for $29 or more.
10 bucks off for any purchase of $29 a
more pro flower bouquets are bouquets.
Police police are guaranteed fresh
for seven days or your money back.
They have seven step quality check, which
means the flowers are always awesome.
Your website is super easy to use.
You can schedule your delivery ahead of
time for any date you want and get you
and get back to your day. Pro Flowers
is a no brainer gift for a birthday,
an anniversary, every occasion,
or even for no occasion at all.
Anytime when you want to. He want
her to feel special. They key.
If you don't want you woman,
my Wallman Don left me,
so I've got some pro flowers
playing at home in her twat.
They take care of all the details.
Do yourself a favor and help out the show
by supporting pro flowers. I know, uh,
I know you have either a birthday or
your anniversary coming up. We'll,
everybody does if you wait long enough.
So right now I'll get $10 $10 off
your purchases for $29 or more.
It pro flowers.
But this deal definitely won't last long.
Just go to proflowers.com and enter the
code [inaudible] at checkout to get this
special deal.
I was wondering why they were going to
be advertising flowers this time a year.
I was like, what are you going
to get into the fucking east?
Get some Ash Wednesday flowers.
Why are they advertising it?
Because you know what,
they probably had their maximum appeal.
They probably hit their maximum fucking,
I just realized it's probably somebody
sleeping on the other side. I mean,
I'm waking him up with my fucking Johnny
paycheck saying, let me get over here.
Um, anyways, so they're
probably like, well,
how can we get people to fucking
buy flowers all year round?
How can we create a need? Well,
everybody's got an anniversary.
Everybody's got a birthday.
Her birthday. Right? Hey,
I like the way you're thinking Carl. We
could sell flowers the whole year round.
Um, all right. stamps.com everybody
the hassle,
man of the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease.
No longterm commitments, um, with no,
no equipment to lease and the longterm
commitments. Click print mail,
and you're done. Unlike the post
office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages
at your convenience. 24, seven,
seven days a week. Stamps saw
calm, brings all the surfaces,
surfaces of the US Postal Service,
right your fingertips by in print,
official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps.com will help you
decide the best class
of mail on your needs.
No need to lease an
expensive postage meter. Um,
I use stamps.com anytime I got posters,
you know,
I'm going to whore myself out after shows.
Um,
which I haven't done in a
minute, but I'm on, you know,
I'm thinking I'm going to start fucking
doing that again. Now that I'm a father.
Now that I got my daughter,
my daughter dawn left me the goal.
The reason I'm okay right now.
You too can enjoy the stamps service
with a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without a longterm commitment.
Um,
go to stamps.com.
Click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com
and
tuber. Alright, I'm getting up against
it here. You know what I'm doing today,
by the way,
I'm going to go see Oh cleo audio.
I'm going to see my dog Cleo. Um, the,
the people that ended up a rest
getting her from us live out here.
So,
um,
I'm actually gonna get to see her and
visit her today and tomorrow and um,
I can't wait to see her and everything.
She's probably not even gonna give a shit
because she's probably going to be so in
love with the other people cause I kind
of realized that going well.
She was in love with the people that
had her before us and within a week she
fucking loved us. I mean, dogs should they
adapt, they just fucking adapt. So, um,
I got another five minutes here
and then I got to take off.
So I got time for one question
here. Let me see. Um, let me get,
let me get a good one here.
Uh, all righty, righty.
A dictator bill.
I'm 19 years old and I've been with
my girlfriend, my Wallman dawn left.
I'm with my girlfriend
from now for two years. Uh,
I know what you're thinking too
young for all these silly problems.
That's not what I'm thinking. I'm thinking
good for you. Way To go where to go.
Fell. Um, anyway, for the
first year of our relationship,
literally everything was perfect. I still
love her just as much as I did then.
I'm sure she loves me just as much.
However,
during the second year of our relationship
relationship and overnight shift
changed,
um,
and then we stopped having sex.
It base,
it's basically nonexistent
and now and again,
every couple of months it will happen.
But I know she's not enjoying it.
This is because she was on the
implant contraception injection.
At first I was questioning myself and
if it was me that wasn't getting her in
the mood anymore, but she promises me
that it isn't because of the implant.
She says it's that it, what the
fuck is it? Contraception injection.
Oh, Jesus. I, I mean I've
never heard of that shit.
It's an injection so
you won't get pregnant.
Yeah,
dude, if you literally told
me contraception actually
meant it's Gunna get you
pregnant,
I would believe that too.
That's like one of those fucking words
that I just ignored my whole life.
You know, like Soliloquy, like what
the fuck does that mean? You know,
contraception,
implant
official site. Get the facts. Fuck that.
I don't want to fax someone pictures.
Images.
Okay. They're showing it
that it's nice and small.
For some reason they keep putting
it up against their bicep.
They stick it in your fucking arm.
What?
So say some fucking robot shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's birth control implant.
They stick a fucking toothpick in your
arm and then you can't have a baby.
I don't get it anyways.
Well yeah,
that's probably fucking annoying to
have it in there. You know what I mean?
She goes to hug you and the inside
of her arm hurts. Anyways, apps.
The first I was questioning myself,
blah, blah. She says that it,
that has caused her to
completely lose her sex drive.
She says she just had it removed and
it's been a few weeks since then.
Nothing has changed yet.
I feel so much resentment towards her
every day and what I can only describe as
depression.
As soon as I see her,
most of the time I find myself being
such an angry, short tempered person.
Now when normally I'm usually
happy and smiling, ah,
Jesus might be time to get out
of this relationship buddy.
But you know something,
if it really affected her like that,
it depends on how long
she had it in there.
Maybe she needs longer than
two weeks. Um, but you know,
if you're gonna be an angry lunatic,
I mean if you don't leave eventually
she's gonna. But you know what,
you get yourself a song on a warm
and Don port or to pick in or arm.
Now she won't suck.
My Dick won't have these days.
I'm going to whip it out
and wipe it on the wall.
You can take my dick and shit.
Um,
Rodney and your fucking mouth, you whore.
But do, do, do, do, do you, do you okay.
I always try.
I always seem to try and hide my need for
sex and act like I don't ever want it.
And tried to show
disinterests but I never can.
I guess it just must be more
important to me than it is to her.
I never thought sex was such a big deal,
but the last year has taught me that when
there's bad sex life in a relationship,
it can really cause the whole
thing to just break down.
It just got to the point now that I've
said we need some space and a break,
because the last thing I want
is to ruin our relationship. Um,
dude, you're fucking miserable man. And
you have to, you have to, you know, it's,
you got to be with somebody and like
understand them and, and you know,
be there when they're going through
a tough time, but like, you know,
if they're not understanding how fucking
miserable you are, you just going to,
you're just going to keep getting
more miserable and then, you know,
then they're going to be miserable.
And then in the end they gonna fucking
break up with you and you're gonna be
like, what the fuck? I should have done
that to them breaking up with somebody.
It's not something you should do to them.
It's something you should do for yourself.
All right? This is the deal, dude.
You're not fucking happy.
All right? You're not happy.
It's great that you
take in a fucking break.
And I would go out and
I'd fucking go try to win,
join myself and meet somebody that doesn't
have a fucking toothpick in their arm
that doesn't want to touch my dick.
You know what I mean?
That's just get down to brass tacks
here. That's what's going on. Right?
They stuck that shit and her and Noah,
you can't stick your shit and hurt.
So I mean why you gotta get the fuck out?
I get up young dog in 19.
What are you gonna Merrier?
What are you in the military?
People in the military getting
married when the 19 you know,
but warmer dawn left. Um,
that's what you do. I, I,
it's just sounds like a,
you sound like you,
you need like a long time away from
each other the way that was red dude,
that sounded like a fucking 40
year old guy wrote that. 19th.
So that's kind of a good sign that
maybe you should get the fuck out. Um,
who knows? But I, I would not say
anything mean I would not. And uh, I just,
you know,
you want to be able to see the person
again and not get a glass to the head.
You know what I mean?
That's kind of what you're going for.
So the art form is you just
tell them how you're feeling.
Okay.
You know, I'm just not happy. I'm
sorry. That's just how I feel.
I'm just not happy and I'm finding
myself less and less happy and,
um, it's affecting my moods.
Everything you just said.
Okay.
And I'm finding that I'm getting angry
and I don't want to be angry around you
and, and create any misery in your life.
So as much as this is going to hurt you,
I'm walking out the door.
You can take this relationship.
Um, that's it. They walk out the door,
you know, and you'll probably walk out
that door and you'd be sad a little bit.
Yeah.
And you walk a little more,
then you start skipping and then you're
running down the street. You know,
it might be one of those breakups. Okay.
Or could be the one, oh, why did I do it?
I don't fucking know. But you're 19.
You don't, if you've got the whole,
you got your whole fucking life ahead
of you. You don't need to be in this.
This sounds like you're fucking married.
I get up. All right. That's it. Okay.
And that's the fucking podcast
for this week. Go fuck yourselves.
I will our check in on you on,
um,
on Thursday and uh, that's
it. I'll let you know how, uh,
Sheetal cleal the next couple of days is,
which is going to be fucking awesome.
And it's also, you know what,
I'm psyched that, you know,
we've got a cool family and uh,
you know,
I think I'll come out to Phoenix
a couple times a year, you know,
do a run of shows like I'm doing here.
Go to a game or something like that.
I'll hang with the dog. It's Kinda
Nice, you know. All right, that's it.
I'll talk to you guys on Thursday.